i love you for so many reasons and over
so many years
and in every capacity but i also
want to zero in if it's okay on christy
cummings
please best in show i mean
i've probably seen that movie at least a
hundred times
no hyper pole i
you and jennifer coolidge in that movie
it's my favorite thing in the world did
you guys have as much fun making it as
it feels watching it
yes we did we shot that in vancouver
jennifer coolidge and i with everybody
else
we had just met we were the uh the new
kids on the block in terms of that that
unofficial christopher guest ensemble we
were both very nervous
but we had a lot of time to just walk
around through stanley park and come up
with funny funny things to say to each
other
yeah we improvised but we also set some
stuff up for ourselves that made
us laugh so we had a blast we became
very good friends and uh
i adore her to this day what is it like
to be with
you know such an incredible cast people
i mean people are cultish about the
christopher guest world which you're
such an important part of
well thank you yeah i'm really uh happy
that i am and i will say this about
working with that group of people
they're all kind of
insecure comedy people we all are all of
us together
and we're all kind of normal and weird
at the same time and we appreciate each
other's kind of oddities
and chris is one of the he doesn't he
doesn't laugh very much
um he doesn't give you much direction
he's very quiet he's a man of very
few words but when you do get him to
laugh and it usually looks like this
that's that's a good laugh for him and
then your heart fills with joy and the
clouds part and the sun shines
was there a moment that the
clouds parted and the oprah aha and
everything made sense of why
you wanted to go into comedy oh
gosh that's a great question and you
know the little things of making the
joke
um in class where you get the attention
and everybody laughs and all of a sudden
you're the coolest person in the world
for
one second but you know i grew up in a
family of um
you know we weren't yucka yucca comedian
type people but
it was a great it was a badge of honor
to be the butt of the joke
and we loved we we had a very healthy
sense
of uh self-deprecation and um you know
when i was able to take that
you know out on stage and to take those
little subtle things i still do this
about people i notice
really subtle things about people mostly
what they're trying to pull off in the
world
and those are the things that i kind of
stockpile in my brain and i
invest my characters with those things
that they think they're pulling off
that that you know kind of their
achilles heel that they're hiding
and that is probably the the most fun in
creating a character is what is this
person hiding
um what does this person think they're
very good at but they're not at all so i
love doing that
i never ever thought of trying to
act like there's something that i don't
want other people to know
yeah the achilles heel what what is my
tenderness that if anybody
pointed it out to me i would dissolve
into a you know pile of dust
that is such a great thing to uh
portray about the human condition
speaking of
humans and family and um you have an
aunt
marge yes or as we call her in chicago
aunt marge
um marge is not only my godmother but
she is my father's only sister and
uh their uh first generation from
ireland so my grandmother was basically
a farm girl
um and my aunt the irish girls all the
brothers are treated like kings
but the irish girls do all the cooking
and the cleaning and everything so she
grew up basically serving
her family and you know took care of my
grandmother until she passed
took care of my uncle john until he
passed and now
like in the last 20 years she has just
come alive in a way she always lived
pretty happily and pretty openly and
with great faith
but she she just came came alive she's
91
she had a boyfriend he just passed away
she had a boyfriend for 20 years and you
know she never married so
it was just uh she's living her life the
way she wants to and
she is the most joyous at peace
person i've ever ever met i always say
my aunt marge is
free she's a free human being
i love that story because i feel like
it's a great
lesson to everyone right now in the face
of
thinking about mortality on a daily
basis
the epicness of us all having to
think listen and behave differently in
2020
but i think i have a personal fear of
reaching my own deathbed and having
not escaped some of the patterns or
behaviors
that i would like to let go like in here
it's it's it's crazy and it's
self-critical
and i'm such a happy person honestly
like it's a such an oxymoron i'm like i
will not get to that deathbed
having still this much noise in there i
want to
feel calm and let go and so i was really
inspired by
aunt marge because i feel like she has
something to teach us all
she sure does there is you know and for
her
her gateway to this life um is
uh she's catholic and she's quite
faithful she goes to church every day
and she
prays and she's you know she's filled
with
the joy of the lord you know and for me
and i know
that you um do a practice mindfulness as
well and um i do tm
in the morning and at night which is
transcendental meditation
and um there's it's not that you get rid
of any thoughts like i don't think
my aunt marge like you know is trying to
get rid of
of thoughts i think you just come to
peace about it and then they're they're
kind of like a radio in another room you
like barely
barely hear them and you barely pay
attention to them